le mental le mental les gars
psychologiquement on doit tous dessus
on vient de la terreur vous
connaissez les historiques du club mbo
faut être vu tout ça la reprise
compliquée pour les templiers dans le
championnat de deuxième division dominés
en début de match sur leur terrain par
les pionniers de touraine
les élans courtois craque une première
fois dans le deuxième quart temps et
sont menés 6 à 0 à la mi temps du match
premier match de saison on connaît pas
les équipes en face on n'a pas eu le
temps de voir voir ce qu'ils voient leur
club ou qu on n'a rien vu de la saison
donc forcément le temps d'adaptation on
a un jeune cube et donc forcément j'ai
créé avec il fallait qu'il prenne ses
marques
en deuxième période les elins courtois
reviennent à hauteur des pionniers avec
ce tout jeune dans le troisième quart
temps avant que la défense
saint-quentinoise ne cède une nouvelle
fois quelques minutes plus tard
finalement les templiers l'emportent 14
à 13 dans le money time sur l'une des
dernière action du match la victoire est
toujours mérité on s'est battu pour pour
aller la chercher
on était mené tout le match on est parti
le chercher sur dernier drive et au
final on a juste marqué un point de plus
que les autres ce qu'il fallait faire
victoire méritée puisque de toute façon
du torse
c'est bon à prendre après la manière
n'est pas forcément là mais avec cette
victoire sur le fil les templiers pointe
à la deuxième place du championnat les
footballeurs se déplaceront sur le
terrain des diables rouges de villepinte
ce samedi 19 janvier résultat positif à
l'extérieur pourrait leur permettre de
croire en leur objectif un titre de
champion de deuxième division en fin de
saison